before i get to a question you two are
incredible in this show you're so good
oh well don't get to any questions
let's start with it this whole time is
just gonna be me praising your
performances in this and i see i mean it
i mean it so hey misha i was reading in
the press notes that you sent in an
audition tape for this one and mike and
trevor said that your take on the
character was super unique in that tape
so what were some of your primary goals
when you put that audition tape together
get hired number one
get hired win the job don't let anyone
else do it instead of me those were my
three priorities i mean it was uh
this was like and it was one of the wor
those terrible auditions sometimes
they'll give you like oh here's a
three-page scene oh seven pages oh
they've given me nine pages and then the
day before i go to tape it they say
would you just do five more so i had 14
pages and i was like no this is
ridiculous but when you start to work on
it because mike is such a good writer it
sort of pours into you in a way that
doesn't really seem fair and
and i get i guess it was
an adequate read on the role to win the
job
all right samantha with bev i feel like
we get a lot of backstory for
most of the other characters in terms of
setting up why they are the way they are
when the show begins and why they make
certain choices we don't get that for
her and we don't necessarily need it but
i find that when i get super fascinated
by a character i need to know everything
about them so just for you with tackling
the role did you ever come up with a
backstory by yourself or with mike to
determine why she has this agenda today
um the backstory from for myself i did
have uh pieces and it was mainly
less about the specifics of her life and
more about how she felt about the island
and so i did feel that um
it was really important to me that she
felt uh in ownership of it and that that
was what's driving her was that she had
decided that she knew exactly how
everything was going to run because she
had been there as long as she had been
and i just feel like she
um
her position
she felt very queen-like over it and i
and so that that was where i was going
and as far as mike's discussion with our
character it was really along those
lines of her belief and her
uh
her belief in her correctness and her
her being right
and that helped me with absolutely
everything because it was a very easy
line to follow about anything i'm saying
anything i'm doing it's with complete
conviction that that is exactly what
should be done comes across very clearly
here's a question for for both of you
another thing that we don't need but
again another thing that because i like
the show and i'm greedy i want to know
about did you ever talk through what the
first conversation was like between bev
and pruitt where he told her exactly
what was going on and what her very
first reaction to it was
okay you be me and i'll be you
okay
uh beverly i think it's very important
you should know who i am
i am actually pruitt
i know it i know it
yeah
that's exactly it
i that's how it went that was how it was
before we prov we pro we do that sort of
we we do swapsie swapsie prozzies
i never would have imagined it that way
but it feels very accurate to me that
was actually very accurate of the inside
for her i mean and the she's living her
she's living her best life by by the end
of this
she's on a good run
all right hamish from pruitt's
perspective one thing that i was
wondering about is
what do you think would have happened if
everything went perfectly according to
plan what might crockett island look
like in the end and then what were some
of his hopes for how that would wind up
changing the world beyond it
uh
this is i mean it's a wonderful question
i think this is
i think if he thinks about it deeply he
thinks this is the next
stage in uh
human evolution i mean is
uh there will be no more death and uh
i i mean i don't know how that works
with uh overpopulation
need to
invest more in space travel at that
point and you think
uh but there will be plenty of time to
work on aerodynamics like the best minds
won't go away anymore in space yeah
uh but uh
i i i think uh the
experience he's had
uh
his
new level of awakening has been so vivid
uh that he
just believes that this is th these are
the right steps that he's taking
all right samantha i have a big old
spoiler question for you right now
because one of the moments that struck
me most is when she runs away in the
church and i'm curious when you're
playing a beat like that
is her running away coming from a place
of just simply being scared of what's
happening or
is there an agenda in her not wanting to
turn
um i
i think it's one of those beautiful
moments where it is her just the
weakness of humanity coming through of
of really seeing in these moments what
she has
wrought in a way and i think
that um
that was a very fun thing to play
because it can almost read humorous if
you if you're watching her kind of like
yoink out the side door it's it's uh and
i love that you get mike went for that
moment when everybody sees me standing
there and um
yeah i think it was fear
i think it was fear for the truth of
what was happening
all right for both of you now because we
don't have enough time to get to every
incredible scene you have in the show
you're both essentially operating at an
11 for like 99 of it so if you had a you
know look at the shooting schedule and
circle one particular day in red that
made you think like that day that day in
particular i'm gonna have my work cut
out for me what would that day be
uh i had like three i had like a week i
had everything happened at once in the
schedule for me um so and like the
sermons were at the end but like all the
the the long aa scenes with uh
with riley uh that happened over sort of
three days and uh
scared the crap out of me for a year as
it turned out
i could never hold a candle to what
hamish is working his way through all
the time and with such made it look easy
but my day
i think is when i'm talking about
putting uh
the carpet scene
uh
for me was
was a mouthful but also
incredibly fun i mean that's the thing
with what mike writes like him just said
you know it's
it's just fun you just kind of ride the
wave of what's on the page
all right i think i have time to squeeze
in one more question unless someone
yells at me uh
hamish one thing i was wondering about
do you have to create a a construct for
your character before and after turning
were there significant changes in who he
was
deep down when he changed in the
supernatural sense
uh
i just i i
try to try to keep it simple and uh
and uh just do just do the right thing
uh from one
scene to the next it's and it does
change like his goal his plan changes as
the show goes on but always focusing on
what the positive uh outcome of each
scene can be
and that uh
sort of is the the lifeline and i will
say one thing and pray many things in
praise of same slang but
the stuff that's harder to memorize out
of these massive things are
are the biblical attacks because then
suddenly you're in mike's rhythm
and then suddenly it sort of like veers
over and you're in old testament rhythm
or some or some other translation thing
and actually sam had the bulk of that
and she would just
glide into it so beautifully and i think
i was dead on the floor or very bloody
on the floor
that day that massive day of uh
in the carpet and uh i was like wow
and then i said again to myself
wow
i said wow quite a bit while watching
this but i mean in all honesty wow you
two are incredible you really knock this
out of the park huge congratulations to
you thank you so much